diese wissenschaftliche Arroganz die bei
ihm durchdringt ich habe großen Respekt
vor Wissenschaftler aber demokratie
heißt das in unserem Staat jede Frau und
jeder Mann das gleiche Recht hat so wie
Herr Zander sich angehört hat mündet
daraus eine ja Anspruch dass er ein
größeren Anspruch hätte gehört zu werden
mit seinen Argumenten bei der
Wissenschaftler ist ja er kann mit
seinen Argumenten entsprechend
rüberkommen aber am Schluss gibt es eine
Abstimmung egal ob der Bundestag gewählt
wird oder eine Volksabstimmung in bei
einem Bürgerentscheid in München
stattfindet und da hat jede Frau und
jedermann das gleiche Recht er kann
nicht mit einer Arroganz auftreten dass
er das besser weiß als der erfahren
oder der Hausmeister vom Innenminister
jetzt mal akzeptieren sie dreht mit
einer Arroganz auf weil sie
Wissenschaftler sind hätten sie einen
Anspruche darauf dass alle auf das zu
hören haben was sie